i mean somebody said to me
somebody asked me the other day what
what do you think the future look like
and i was i was bastardizing the the
orwell quote from 1984 and and i i said
it's uh it's a laptop screen smashing
you you in the face forever
i'm not sure that that sitting in our
offices
glued to this
screen is is necessarily that healthy
either so
so somewhere in the middle but i'm not
quite sure how we get there
no because i'm sorry constantine no go
ahead mate no because it just seems to
me that this way that we're living
it doesn't seem sustainable if you go
back to you know the the nine to five
and it didn't seem looking back on it
that it was particularly effective
either but you know people have done it
for generations therefore we carried on
surely the next generation of
innovators and people coming out of it
are going well we've actually managed to
break that now we've seen that it
doesn't work therefore let's try this
new way
well i think we'll definitely have i
think one of the economics effect on
economic effects of of this
situation will be
the relative growth of the virtual
uh over the real if you like so the
virtual economy over the real economy so
so so you'll see more
um cloud-based activity more remote
activity and and certainly if you think
about um contingency planning for
businesses now where they used to have
warehouses full of desks that everyone
could go to
that's that's gone now hasn't it so
there's going to be a whole different
whole different way of of thinking about
how you how you plan
uh for this kind of emergency or this
kind of this kind of interruption
business interruption going forward so i
think that i think there will be changes
um
and people will work from home or i'm
just not sure we'll get to that
fundamental
change that's that that is necessary
which is
is more holistic
it's it's it's the context of our lives
uh you know it is is the big thing that
i
i think is even underlined even more
is is that technology is not saving you
any time
it's not making you any happier
you are constantly
available
i mean the whole world's on shut down
and yet everybody's cooped up in a room
somewhere
you know talking into a team's call
um
it's not improving
our lives it hasn't made it hasn't given
us any more free time so
so
is it do we need a a much more
fundamental
reset
i don't know
something more for another more
fundamental virus to shut us down even
more that's what we need is what mike is
exactly what he's saying but uh mike uh
what is it that we're not seeing what is
it that we're not talking about what do
you
with a kind of totally different mindset
to most people that i know
what what is
out of our field of vision that's coming
well i think one of the consequences i
mean i think people are talking about
this but my
my biggest fear and it's not my biggest
fear for for the economy or the country
maybe the biggest fear for the country
is the civil liberties implication of of
what will come
after this um
rushing a vaccine through that's a
frightening prospect
um in many ways vaccinate vaccinating
many young people who
who don't necessarily need a vaccine is
is
concerning um thinking about how you're
going to be monitored how you're going
to be tagged how how
uh your movements are going to be big
brothered um i think all of these things
i think is it jeremy bentham and the
concept of the people's behavior changed
the panopticon if they're watched all
the time the behavior changes and i
think that's quite dynamic amongst
populations as well i think for some
people for many people and it kind of
goes back to the the huxley and the the
brave new world view of where we are
because they is they may embrace that
they may embrace that um
that that that sort of monitoring that
herding to use the phrase in a different
way well there's many many other people
and they're the people that affect
change who are going to find that
intolerable
so
it took breaking the law
to change many of the things that we now
take for granted be it
the suffragettes or
homosexuality or many of those things um
it took people who who who who are
prepared to step outside the boundaries
and similarly the way
the way most entrepreneurial people
think is is is to be
is to be outside of the mainstream
and i think if we limit that
and i think that is that is perhaps the
thing that worries me most is we will
limit
the ability of those people who affect
change to do so
and so where where will that where will
that leave us in a very homogenous
world that's not a world i particularly
want to live in mike well let me push
back on that a little bit because as you
know i you know if there was anyone who
was concerned about the erosion of our
civil liberties restrictions of free
speech that's me i've been pretty
outspoken about this for a long time but
i've got to be honest with you i don't i
look around i mean yes in australia
they're talking about some kind of app
to track your immunity status and and
that would be a hill that i'm i'm
prepared to die on i'm not signing up to
any [ __ ] app that tracks me around
the country no way
but but if you can't travel would you
right
but this is yeah i mean yeah i mean this
is exactly this is exactly my point if
someone said to you
uh your passport is dependent on you
carrying your contact tracing app yeah
then then most of us would and it erodes
doesn't it so it starts with a contract
tracing app and where does it go after
that right but my broader point i mean i
take your point on that and that is a
step way too far in my opinion but more
broadly speaking i do see the the you
know a lot of the people we've had on
the show who we like and respect kind of
in my opinion going way off the deep end
on this stuff and talking about how
we're all under house arrest and all
this crap which i i think is a massive
exaggeration i think a temporary and
necessary lockdown is not the same as
house arrest i personally don't feel
like western governments have been
overly restrictive about this in in
proportion to the threat that we're
facing you know it is a war-like time
you accept a little bit more imposition
on your freedoms during that time
provided their time limited provided
their specific provided we can go back
to
you know having a free society
afterwards are you do you see signs that
that's not going to happen is
what what what's the reason for your
concern
i i never trust people in power to give
the keys back
um once once once once they get was
similar to the the
um mmt
conversation that we had earlier once
you give um people in power power
uh and consider that their
their reasons for living or they are to
obtain power
they really don't like giving it back
um so
i i do i
while i might not be at the
the further end of the spectrum of the
previous guests you've had
i
we we as a country as a as a species
have
fought and lost millions of lives to
maintain
uh freedoms and i don't think that
should be lost um there are consequences
there's serious consequences to giving
up
um giving up the things that
that enable us to change and i think
that's that's that's what scares me most
is
when you have
a
contact tracing app that you need to
have
you have you've given
um
the political order
a lever
in with which to dictate or with which
to demand your your obedience
and anything that does that anything
that does that more i think that's that
would be very very worrying and you say
you'd die on a hill for it but the
reality is most people won't
[Music]